search in rivers and on beaches worries
about the cost of water and profits made
by firms and now the country's biggest
water company supplying fully a quarter
of the population Thames water is on the
brink of collapse we'll know better
labor front venture to talk to us this
evening than the shadow environment
secretary this is Jim McMahon
lots of concern over the future of
Thames water how worried should we be
well I think it is a worry you know the
largest water company in Britain it's
got deaths of 14 billion pounds that are
built up it's got millions of people who
rely on it for its clean water for this
for dealing with the uh the sewage and
you know rightly people are concerned
about what that means in particular if
it requires a government-led bailout
that's then ultimately added to the bill
payers and so we've been holding the
government to account we brought today a
urgent question to Parliament the
secretary it didn't even bother to turn
up to answer the question and so you
know for me it does raise kind of real
concerns about whether the government
have got a grip on this or whether
they've been taken by complete surprise
because they haven't organized well
enough so what needs to happen then what
should happen well the question for the
government really is is this the canary
in the coal mine is this really speaking
to a wider vulnerability in our water
industry where 72 billion pounds has
been taken out in shareholder dividends
we haven't seen money invested to reduce
leaks and sewage discharges what should
happen though that's the question what
right now Thames water lots of people
will be very worried if you are in
government what would you do well this
point the regulator has the power to
have a court order to essentially take
control of the water company to make
sure they continue to trade and service
its customers and we understand those
talks are taking place today if we were
in government well you would expect me
to say we wouldn't be here in the first
place because we are not surprised by
this you know we've had the warnings of
financial vulnerability from off what
themselves who have said oh but two of
the water companies in England and Wales
are above the debt levels that they're
comfortable with that they agreed to in
the last price review and It just
strikes me that we haven't got the right
balance here we've allowed those
shareholder dividends to go out on one
hand 72 billion pound we've allowed debt
now to reach levels of 60 billion pound
that we're all paying for for our bills
and now we're requiring forward
investment to deal with the water
shortages where leaks are losing water
and also sewage discharges where our
rivers lakes and seas are being
completely disrespected we're all human
sewage well you've spelled out the
problem right yeah does that mean that
labor would bring the water companies
back under government control would you
nationalize them well we said as a point
so this is for the industry overall
taken to one side of the issue
immediately with terms which is as a
point of principle why should working
people pay twice they've already paid
through their bills for water companies
would labor nationalize the water
companies we believe that the water
companies they've taken 72 billion pound
of shareholder dividends should be made
to fix a system that's broken would
labor nationalize award companies well
the answer is no because the water
companies have to put right the system
that they've taken 72. I'll be honest I
think there'll be an awful lot of people
listening to you thinking I agree with
you these Dividends are ridiculous look
at this 1.4 billion pounds in dividends
the water companies last year that's
outrageous sewage in the rivers and the
Seas that is outrageous as well and of
course now these Financial
vulnerabilities as well why won't you
nationalize them but at this point why
should Bill payers because that's who
would pay you the bill of
nationalization why should Bill payers
pay water company shareholders who have
already taken over 70 billion pound out
the system why should they pay them for
an artificial inflation they could uh
ownership
service better water and cheap in the
long term I guess but I think that's
about regulation in the end and we can
require instead of losing that 1.8 to 2
billion pound every single year in
dividend payments as an average we can
direct water companies to use that to
fix a sewage Scandal to fix the leaks
where we're having water shortages
that's got to be the first protocol
before we go to nationalization now
clearly we have to deal with all
eventualities and if we have a system a
water industry that has market failure
we're not seeing that on a systemic
level yet but we are concerned about
Thames then of course you need to look
at that environment at that point in
time but that's not where we are today
what about the regulator of what has
that failed well it's pretty clear that
the regulator has very big questions to
answer but in the end the regulator will
only ever be as strong as a government
gives it direction to be strong and
gives it the powers to be strong and I
observe frankly a secretary of state and
a conservative government that haven't
given it the importance that's needed
haven't given it the strength of
ambition that's needed and haven't given
them the powers that's needed to put
this right so absolutely they can do
more but it requires leadership from the
conservative government to really give
them the direction
um now the times have just published a
story in the last hour or so to say that
case Dharma is planning to reshuffle his
top team in the next month or so I just
want to read a quote to you from the
piece and the quote is Jim McMahon is
likely to be demoted from Shadow
environment secretary with labor
determined to do more about water
cleanliness
doesn't sound great for you uh well I
mean listen first of all that's
speculation and I'm very proud of the
word that I've done in the environment
brief you know the way that we have
really brought now to the Public's
attention what's really been going on
here's Diamond might be listening but I
I'm pretty confident that I've done a
good job on water that I've done a good
job on access uh to Nature that we've
done a good good job on food security
now clearly I'm not going to speculate
about a future reshuffle but I can say
in terms of my record in the post that
I'm very proud of what I've done and I
would just say this how many people had
it in their Consciousness that raw human
sewage was being dumped in their Rivers
their Lakes and their Seas of course
because of the campaigners but also
because the way that labor has given
from the front bench and I've LED from
the front on that in a way that I'm very
proud of because I believe in the end it
comes down to what does it mean to live
a decent fulfilled Life as a working
person and having quality of life is
really important to that so speculating
to one side I'm very proud of what doing
this job
I mean this in the
nicer little bit like you're trying
you're almost acknowledging that you are
like to lose your job and you're just
trying to pitch film your record
but but I'm not for a star and I'm not
going to get into the speculation and
the motivations uh behind it uh but
listen the environment brief is a
coveted brief and I wouldn't be
surprised at all if more people were
looking at it and saying with the
profile that we've raised in terms of
food Security in terms of the water
industry in terms of Nature and all that
has to offer of course I would expect
other people so it wasn't coming from
you maybe maybe they're who briefed but
I'm very proud of the work uh that I've
done uh and I do think that is seen by
others okay
um are you quick at them and not
particularly no what did you make of the
year I think I just battered that one
away hopefully
very good
um what did you make of the uh just of
oil protesters interrupt in the ashes
well I mean I think as a general rule if
we want Everyday People to believe that
the climate crisis is something that
they have to make a contribution to
individually and collectively we've got
to bring people with us and I think any
measures that really set the general
public against the argument isn't
helpful so I can understand why they
feel the need to do it because it gets
attention and we're talking about it
today but I definitely don't believe
that's the way to win the hearts and
minds of the general public okay thank
you very much thank you